hey catherine how are you
hi i'm good how are you
good you know i just watched a film last
night and it's been overwhelming i'm
still absorbing everything that i
watched and this being on it based on a
true story it is pretty spectacular what
was it like for you to watch the film
for the first time
oh wow i actually saw a few different
cuts um as an actress and
co-producer on it but just to see the
end products
um i didn't get a chance to see until
cancer festival i know that we did the
last minute edit it was like 24 hours
before the deadline to make it and it
was so amazing just to see it on the big
screen in france and ken and seeing um
all the hard work and
and seeing it all kind of come together
in a beautiful way
it was amazing
and the response that can was massive
four minutes
standing i mean
how does it work it was such a
surreal moment and pretty amazing and um
so
deserving of sean and dylan and just to
be part of that and seeing the response
i think this film will touch a lot of
hearts and and a lot of people's lives
in
such a way that you will walk away a
different person when you see it and
you'll feel these characters you would
see the relationship
yeah get an intimate portrait of who
they are
and sean as a director i mean this is a
sixth feature film it's been 30 years
since he's been able to direct and this
seems like a really important story for
him to reflect on and to be part of this
project what was it that you felt that
you've learned from him
sean is such
an incredible soul such a beautiful
human being and a humanitarian and such
an
inspiration as a director and as an
actor just to see him in his element and
his best element as a director and actor
was remarkable this took over 15 years
to get made um i know sean was involved
very early on i think he wanted to
accent it and then just direct it and it
wasn't last minute he got involved in
acting in its very last minute um and
stepping into the shoes i originally
they had someone else involved and i
read the script over the weekend and i
called my agent i'm like i need to move
on i need to be part of this
and i think that there was someone else
that really wanted to do it and they
were about to close the deal and i ended
up calling sean and i wrote him in this
email saying i'm on the next flight to
minnesota wherever you are
sit down with me and i got on the plane
and i got a chance to sit down with them
and i convinced them why i should be
patty and um lucky enough to be part of
such a remarkable movie
and catherine what was it like for you
to see yourself as patti because we see
you evolve into this
nurturing mom almost at the end right
it's a tufts that you have a mother too
so it's really difficult to watch and
there's a scene where you know dylan's
character says you know jennifer says uh
you know all you have to do is protect
us that's all you have to do but for you
to see you embodying patty the way that
she was growing as an older lady what
were your thoughts on all that
oh wow that was one of the hardest
things to shoot is like the kitchen
scene was one of the hardest that was my
very first scene with dylan and
um i think it was my first week of
shooting and it was so intense to be
able to
to to get it wasn't originally written
that way first of all and and and sean
just created such an environment we had
a no phone policy on set and created a
quiet workspace to really allows us to
explore
different ways and of course we got
there and
as um
as a mother to
as playing a mother
to to justify why she she's in her mind
she's trying to protect her daughter
from
what she knows
of of
of john fogle's character that he's a
liar and he's a carmen i think she's
trying to really protect her daughter in
that moment even though
it's questionable in terms of how she's
doing it and and it for me as an actor
to be able to evolve so much throughout
the decades from
70s and seeing me as a young mom to an
alcoholic
and a struggling single mom to
really in a full prosthetic
uh and aging a piece um and finally at
peace with ourselves and asking for
forgiveness was was such a journey as an
actor that you don't really get that
opportunity very often and i loved it i
absolutely loved every moment of that
catherine you're brilliant thank you so
much and i can't wait for everyone to
see this film congratulations to you
thank you
you